MS. OF      ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT AS THE BRETT KAVANAUGH
SAGA HAS JUST REMINDED US, THE
LEFT ROOTS AROUND FOR PEOPLE
THEY DON'T LIKE.
THE QUESTION IS, DO THEY APPLY
THE SAME STANDARD TO THEMSELVES?
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS ABOUT THE
PAST OF A WELL-KNOWN PROGRESSIVE
WHO ONCE AGAIN CONFIRMS THAT
NOEL.
THE STANDARDS ARE NOT THE SAME.
WE WILL BRING THAT TO YOU IN
JUST A MINUTE.
BUT FIRST, HERE'S A QUICK QUIZ.
WHAT EXACTLY DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS?
CAN YOU NAME THREE THINGS SHE
BELIEVES?
CAN YOU NAME A SINGLE THING
SHE'S ACCOMPLISHED?
MOST AMERICANS CANNOT.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO SHE IS.
THE ONE THING YOU KNOW ABOUT
HARRIS IS THAT SHE COULD VERY
EASILY BECOME THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AND YOU KNOW THIS BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT CONFIDENTLY AGAIN
AND AGAIN ON TELEVISION.
>> THE NAME I'M HEARING NOW,
BECAUSE THERE WAS A SHE THE
PEOPLE SERVING IN POLITICS.
NUMBER ONE NAME OF PEOPLE, THE
PERSON THAT IS ON PEOPLE'S MIND
PEERED KAMALA HARRIS.
>> BARACK OBAMA.
>> KAMALA HARRIS IS NOW RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
AND SHE IS ONE OF THE TOP TIER
CANDIDATES.
>> THERE IS A NEW CHALLENGER TO
TRUMP AND SHE'S DRAWING HUGE
CROWDS, SENATOR, HARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA.
TRUMP IS ENVIOUS AS.
>> ON PAPER, SHE HAS THE HIGHEST
CEILING.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE ARE SO
STUPID, IT'S REMARKABLE.
KAMALA HARRIS, SHE IS A STAR.
DESTINE FOR BIG THINGS.
SHE'S LIKE OBAMA, 2.0.
EVEN MORE DIVERSITY POINTS OUT
THERE IN AMERICA.
THEY LOVE KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE'S LIKE PETE SEEGER.
FOR EIGHT MONTHS, THEY TRY TO
CRAM THAT STORY DOWN YOUR THROA
THROAT.
"THE TIMES" HAS LOOKED ALMOST
SEMIPOSSIBLE IF WE CLOSE ONE EY
EYE.
SHE DID NONSTICK JOE BIDEN AS A
RACIST.
IT LATER EMERGED THAT HARRIS
HERSELF HAD DOUBTS ABOUT SCHOOL
BUSING.
IN FACT, ALMOST NO AFRICAN
FAMILY IN AMERICA SUPPORTED
SCHOOL BUSING.
IT WAS AND     A DISASTER.
YEAH, BRUTAL.
JUST DOMINATED THE GUY.
TURNS OUT SHE DIDN'T ACTUALLY
DOMINATE ANYBODY AND SHE'S NOT
DOMINATING ANYBODY.
A NEW POLL FROM CALIFORNIA,
OBVIOUSLY HER HOME STATE, WHICH
SHE REPRESENTS IS THE
UNITED STATES SENATE SHOWS HER
WAY IN THE BACK OF THE PACK.
SHE IS NOW IN FIFTH PLACE.
SHE'S PULLING AT 6%.
HERE ARE SOME PERSPECTIVE.
AS OF TODAY, KAMALA HARRIS IS
USING TO ANDREW YANG, THE
ANTI-CIRCUMCISION CANDIDATE.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF HIS IDEAS,
HE IS SMART, HE IS ORIGINAL,
HE'S TOTALLY GENUINE.
HARRIS IS THE OPPOSITE.
HARRIS, BY THE WAY IT IS A
DAUGHTER OF A STANFORD
PROFESSOR, WHICH IS GREAT.
GOOD FOR HER.
AND YET, SHE SOMEHOW PRETENDS
THAT SHE OVERCAME SEGREGATION.
SHE IS ALSO A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
SHE PUT OTHERS IN JAIL FOR
MARIJUANA, BUT SHE NOW BRAGS
ABOUT SMOKING IT HERSELF.
SHE'S COOL.
[LAUGHTER]
[LAUGHS]
MIND WAS CHILDREN OF PRIVILEGE.
THEY FIND THE WHOLE THING
TOTALLY UNBEARABLE, BECAUSE IT
IS UNBEARABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE KAMALA HARRIS
CAMPAIGN IS DOOMED TO DRIVE
AWAY.
EVEN THE PRESS HAS ABANDONED
HER.
THEIR NEW CRUSH,
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
>> HOW CONSEQUENTIAL WAS THAT
RALLY LAST NIGHT?
NOT JUST WHAT SHE SAID BUT THE
FOUR HOURS OF SELFIES AFTERWARD?
WE ARE JUST LEARNING THAT SHE
TOOK SOME 4,000 SELFIES?
FOUR HOURS TAKING SELF'S?
>> SHE'S OUT THERE TAKING
SELFIES.
BECAUSE SHE SPENT FOUR HOURS
TAKING SELFIES.
>> THAT'S REMARKABLE.
>> YEAH, 4,000.
THE CAMPAIGN SAYS 59,000 SINCE
SHE HAS STARTED RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> SOME PEOPLE WAITED FOR HOURS
TO HAVE A SELF HE TAKEN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S TRUE.
SHE IS IN FACT THE FRONT RUNNER
IN THE DEMOCRATIC RACE.
TECHNICALLY, JOE BIDEN IS
PULLING IN FIRST PLACE, BUT
NOBODY EXPECTS THAT TO LAST.
>> YOU KNOW, IF I WERE JUST 80
YEARS OLD --
[LAUGHTER]
>> I DON'T BELIEVE I COULD
UNDERTAKE THE DUTIES THAT I
EXPERIENCED WHEN I WAS PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE
WITH YOUR MIND.
YOU HAD TO BE ABLE TO GO FROM
ONE SITE      THE SUBJECT FROM N
ONE SITE      THE SUBJECT FROM T
ONE SITE      THE SUBJECT FROM E
ONE SITE      THE SUBJECT FROM .
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO CONCENTRATE.
NOT A SUBTLE DIG.
OVER 75 YEARS OLD.
YET, SHE WOULD STILL BE WAY
YOUNGER THAN JOE BIDEN OR
BERNIE SANDERS.